(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Essa é uma das aulas mais importantes do
curso, é uma das aulas mais importantes desse
módulo de leilão judicial.
É a aula que a gente vai falar
sobre o concurso de credores e a análise
pelas dívidas que o arrematante pode ser responsável
do imóvel.
Lá no módulo 2, em leilão extrajudicial, a
gente viu que é de certa forma simples.
Você vai precisar analisar no edital do leilão
se a responsabilidade por dívida de condomínio e
IPTU serão do vendedor, na responsabilidade do comprador.
Então, você vai analisar isso lá no edital
do leilão extrajudicial.
Aqui no leilão judicial, isso também consta no
edital do leilão, mas não é tão simples
de interpretar e, às vezes, é necessário analisar
o concurso de credores.
Então, o objetivo dessa aula é explicar isso
para vocês, para que vocês saibam corretamente qual
é a responsabilidade pelas dívidas que o arrematante
pode carregar em um leilão judicial.
Então, concurso de credores e análise do edital
quanto aos débitos do executado e do imóvel.
Em primeiro lugar, a gente precisa fazer uma
diferença das dívidas do executado e dívidas do
imóvel.
Em regra, o arrematante só pode ser responsável
pelas dívidas do imóvel.
Exemplo, condomínio e IPTU.
Dívidas do executado não podem ser de responsabilidade
do arrematante.
Então, exemplos de dívidas que o executado pode
ter ali e que não podem passar para
o arrematante.
O arrematante não será responsável por pagar essas
dívidas.
Cartão de crédito, cheque especial, dívida trabalhista, dívida
de pensão alimentícia, dívida de alguma indenização.
Nada disso pode ser repassado para o arrematante.
O arrematante, realmente, ele só pode ser responsabilizado
pelas dívidas do imóvel.
Então, é muito importante saber fazer essa distinção
do que é uma dívida do imóvel e
do que é uma dívida do executado.
Se for uma dívida do executado que não
tem a relação com o imóvel, não pode
ser de responsabilidade do arrematante.
O arrematante não terá que arcar com essa
dívida.
Se for uma dívida do imóvel, aí sim
o arrematante precisa analisar a sua responsabilidade se,
de fato, arrematar aquele imóvel.
Interessado, ele precisa fazer essa análise para saber
se, ao arrematar aquele imóvel, ele pode ser
responsável por alguma dívida do imóvel.
As dívidas do imóvel são dívidas propterrain.
O que são dívidas propterrain?
São as dívidas que existem em razão do
bem.
Então, a dívida existe, realmente, porque o bem
existe.
Então, alguém tem que pagar condomínio todo mês
porque existe um imóvel localizado dentro de um
condomínio.
Alguém tem que pagar IPTU anual de um
imóvel porque o imóvel existe.
Se aquele imóvel não existisse, não existiria essa
dívida de IPTU.
Então, o conceito é simples assim.
É uma dívida propterrain porque o próprio bem
existe.
Então, essa dívida existe em razão da própria
existência do bem.
Essas dívidas, elas têm uma característica que, em
regra, elas acompanham um bem.
Então, por isso que é importante a gente
fazer essa análise das dívidas do imóvel num
leilão judicial para saber se o arrematante vai
ser responsável ou não por essas dívidas.
Vamos ver aqui o que fala o Código
Civil sobre as dívidas propterrain.
Código Civil, artigo 1345.
O adquirente de unidade responde pelos débitos do
alienante em relação ao condomínio, inclusive multas e
juros moratórios.
O que esse artigo aqui está falando?
Não importa quantas vezes um imóvel mude de
titularidade, se existir dívidas de condomínio, essa dívida
sempre poderá ser cobrada do novo titular, do
novo proprietário.
Então, vamos supor que eu vendi um imóvel
para o João e esse meu imóvel tinha
dívidas de condomínio da época que eu era
proprietária.
No momento que o João comprou esse imóvel,
se ele não tomou os devidos cuidados para
saber da existência dessa dívida, ele vai ser
o responsável por essa nova dívida e o
condomínio poderá cobrar diretamente do João, apesar da
dívida ter sido feita antes mesmo do João
ser proprietário, porque era uma dívida da minha
propriedade, do tempo que eu era proprietária.
Mas o João comprou, não tomou os devidos
cuidados, a dívida acompanha o bem, porque ela
é uma dívida próprio terreno, ela adere ao
bem e poderá ser cobrada normalmente de João.
Vamos seguir aqui quais são as dívidas dos
imóveis.
Em primeiro lugar, os impostos que podem ser
vinculados ao imóvel.
IPTU se for um imóvel urbano e TR
se for um imóvel rural.
Então, você sempre precisa fazer análise das dívidas
de imposto que existe ali naquele imóvel.
A gente já falou disso várias vezes aqui
antes no curso, porque lá no leilão judicial,
a gente precisa levantar as dívidas de IPTU
para realmente analisar nossa viabilidade financeira, se o
edital do leilão passar essa responsabilidade para o
arrematante.
Então, para você buscar a dívida de IPTU
aqui no leilão judicial, você vai fazer da
mesma forma.
Você vai pegar lá o número do contribuinte,
que geralmente está localizado na matrícula do imóvel
ou que o próprio leiloeiro já coloca ali
destacado para as pessoas interessadas naquele leilão, vai
recorrer ao site da prefeitura daquele município onde
o imóvel fica situado, usar esse número do
contribuinte e aí sim pesquisar os débitos de
IPTU.
Cotas condominiais.
Condomínio é uma dívida próprio terreno, é uma
dívida que acompanha o bem, como a gente
acabou de olhar no Código Civil, como é
que o Código Civil fala do condomínio.
Então, você também precisa avaliar as dívidas de
condomínio que existam naquele imóvel.
Essas dívidas aí, você também vai pesquisar da
mesma forma que a gente falou em todo
o módulo 2, recorrendo ao contato com o
condomínio, com o síndico, com a administradora do
condomínio para levantar essa informação.
No próprio edital já pode constar esse valor
ali das dívidas de condomínio, você só vai
conferir se realmente aquele montante está correto e
aí sim você vai saber o montante que
existe de dívida de condomínio.
Taxa de bombeiro.
Isso é uma taxa que existe em algumas
cidades do Brasil.
Por exemplo, no Rio de Janeiro existe essa
taxa de bombeiro.
Então, se você quiser arrematar no Rio, você
precisa ficar atento a essa taxa de bombeiro.
Geralmente, quando a gente faz lá no Rio
de Janeiro que existe essa taxa, quando a
gente pesquisa o IPTU, já vem lá uma
certidão falando as dívidas de IPTU que existem
e as dívidas de taxa de bombeiro, se
for o caso.
Dívidas de INSS.
Essas são as dívidas de construção do imóvel.
Então, essas dívidas, elas existem porque aquele imóvel
foi construído, precisou de pessoas para a construção
daquele imóvel e aí esses funcionários tinham o
direito a ter recolhido o seu INSS.
Quem faz a obra deve pagar o INSS.
Então, essa também é uma dívida que pode
acompanhar o bem.
Uma dica para a dívida de INSS.
A dívida de INSS prescreve em cinco anos.
Então, você tem que tomar cuidado, principalmente com
os imóveis mais novos, porque se for um
imóvel mais antigo, com mais de cinco anos
e não tiver lá nenhuma informação da matrícula
que existe, há ali uma cobrança de dívida
de INSS, provavelmente não existe, aquele imóvel já
está livre e você também pode observar na
própria matrícula, nos registros anteriores, porque geralmente quando
tem a venda da construtora para uma pessoa,
a construtora apresenta a certidão negativa de débitos
de INSS.
Se constar ali, em algum registro anterior na
matrícula, essa certidão negativa de débitos de INSS,
tudo bem, você sabe que você está livre
daquela dívida também, mas lembre sempre do prazo
de prescrição de cinco anos.
Então, fique atento a isso nos imóveis mais
novos.
E aforamento ou infiteuse?
O que é aforamento ou infiteuse?
O imóvel foreiro, que é realmente o imóvel
que tem um aforamento ou uma infiteuse, é
o que teve a transferência do direito de
usar, gozar, fruir e alienar o imóvel.
Essa transferência desse direito de usar, gozar, fruir
e alienar o imóvel, ela tem um caráter
perpétuo e tem que ser registrado na matrícula
de um imóvel.
Exemplos de imóveis foreiros, terrenos de marinha, terrenos
da União e terrenos de município.
Vamos aqui para exemplos concretos de imóveis foreiros.
A Orla de Copacabana, no Rio de Janeiro,
era terreno de marinha.
Como a União, que é a detentora desses
terrenos de marinha, que são os terrenos que
ficam ali localizados na costa e que são
importantes para a própria defesa aqui do Estado,
ela não tinha interesse em utilizar aquele imóvel,
ela cedeu esse domínio útil para as pessoas
há muito tempo atrás.
Essas pessoas, então, receberam esse domínio útil e
aí elas têm o direito de usar, gozar,
fruir e alienar o imóvel.
O que significa na prática?
Eram terrenos, as pessoas construíram e aí elas
têm direito ali a ter a posse, elas
podem vender aquele imóvel, elas podem alugar aquele
imóvel, elas podem usar aquele imóvel da forma
que elas entenderem.
Em todos esses terrenos, hoje em dia, existem
prédios, em todos esses prédios existem apartamentos e
todos esses apartamentos também são imóveis foreiros, porque
o terreno era um imóvel foreiro.
O que eu preciso que você entenda é
que o imóvel foreiro, ele não deixa de
ter valor econômico.
Veja, estou falando aqui de imóveis localizados na
Orla de Copacabana, que são imóveis super valorizados,
as pessoas pagam milhões para morar naqueles apartamentos.
Então, esses apartamentos não deixam de ter valor
econômico, porque eles são um imóvel foreiro.
Outro exemplo de imóvel foreiro, para o pessoal
aqui de São Paulo, em Barueri, em Alphaville,
existem vários terrenos que eram da União.
A União também não tinha interesse em usar
esses terrenos, cedeu o domínio útil para pessoas.
Em vários desses terrenos, existem condomínios de casas
que são verdadeiras mansões e todas essas casas
também serão imóveis foreiros, já que o terreno
era um imóvel foreiro.
Os proprietários dessas casas, eles podem usar como
eles quiserem, eles podem alugar e eles podem
vender essas casas normalmente.
E aí, a pessoa que comprar também vai
ser dona de um imóvel foreiro, mas isso
não retira o valor econômico.
Essas casas também custam alguns milhões de reais.
Então, eles têm exemplos assim espalhados pelo Brasil.
Várias cidades do Nordeste, que são cidades que
têm Orla, também têm imóveis foreiros e nem
por isso esses imóveis deixam de ser valorizados.
O imóvel foreiro, ele tem sim outras contrapartidas.
Em troca desse domínio útil, da transferência desse
domínio útil, existem ali taxas que devem ser
pagas e são duas.
Primeiro, o foro anual.
Esse é um valor que deve ser pago
todo ano pela utilização desse domínio útil.
Seria mais uma dívida ali que a pessoa
tem para pagar, além do IPTU anual.
A pessoa que tem um imóvel foreiro, que
fica localizado ali em um terreno que teve
essa transferência do domínio útil, além de pagar
o IPTU todo ano, ela também deve pagar
o foro anual.
E existe também o laudêmio.
E o laudêmio só existe na compra e
venda desse imóvel foreiro.
Então, a gente sabe que a pessoa recebeu
ali o domínio útil, ela pode usar da
forma que ela quiser.
Inclusive, ela pode vender aquele imóvel.
Quando existir essa compra e venda, vai ter
que ser pago o laudêmio para o titular
ali daquele domínio útil que foi transferido.
Então, no imóvel foreiro, a gente tem duas
figuras.
O senhorio, que é quem transferiu esse domínio
útil, e o enfiteuta, que é quem recebeu
esse domínio útil.
O enfiteuta vai fazer o que ele quiser
com aquele imóvel.
Ele pode construir, ele pode morar, ele pode
alugar, ele pode vender.
E aí, ele se compromete a pagar essas
duas taxas.
Uma taxa anual, que é o foro anual,
pelo uso daquele domínio útil.
E essa taxa na compra e venda, que
é o laudêmio, que vai ser pago ao
senhorio.
Então, isso é a característica de um imóvel
foreiro.
Novas constituições estão proibidas pelo Código Civil.
Então, o nosso Código Civil que está em
vigência hoje em dia, proíbe as novas constituições
de imóveis foreiros.
Mas os que já existiam, continuam existindo.
E aí, você precisa saber que se você
olhar na matrícula de imóvel e sempre vai
estar informado na matrícula de imóvel que aquele
imóvel é foreiro, você precisa saber que existem
essas duas consequências a mais.
O arrematante, então, ele não pode ficar responsável
por dívidas pessoais do devedor.
Alguns exemplos de dívidas pessoais.
Dívidas trabalhistas, dívidas de indenização, pensão alimentícia e
etc.
Então, vamos supor que você está ali analisando
o imóvel que está indo a leilão.
Ao abrir a matrícula daquele imóvel, você vai
se deparar ali com uma dívida trabalhista.
Essa dívida trabalhista é uma dívida pessoal do
devedor.
O arrematante jamais poderá pagar essa dívida trabalhista.
Se tiver ali uma dívida por uma cobrança
de uma pensão alimentícia, é uma dívida pessoal
do devedor.
O arrematante não vai ser responsável por aquela
dívida.
Se tiver uma dívida de uma indenização de
algum acidente, por exemplo, de trânsito que aquele
devedor se envolveu, aquela penhora ali, daquele processo
registrado na matrícula, também é uma dívida pessoal
do devedor.
O arrematante não pode ser responsável.
O que o arrematante precisa ficar realmente de
olho são as dívidas do imóvel, que são
essas dívidas que a gente acabou de ver,
porque, em regra, o arrematante pode ser responsabilizado
pelas dívidas do imóvel, já que essas dívidas
são dívidas de próprio terrem e acompanham o
bem.
Aqui eu preciso de uma atenção muito grande
de vocês.
Dívidas de alienação fiduciária.
E aí você precisa voltar lá na aula
de leilão de direitos, leilão judicial de direitos,
se você não lembrar bem o que significa
esse tipo de leilão.
Por que você tem que tomar atenção com
dívidas de alienação fiduciária?
Porque essas dívidas de alienação fiduciária, elas não
são dívidas que a gente chama de próprio
terrem.
Afinal de contas, não é uma dívida que
existe especificamente por existir o imóvel.
Por quê?
Porque a dívida garantida por uma alienação fiduciária,
na maioria das vezes, ela é uma dívida
feita para alguém comprar o imóvel, financiar aquele
imóvel.
Só que essa dívida não necessariamente vai existir.
Afinal de contas, eu posso comprar aquele imóvel
à vista.
Então, dívidas garantidas por alienação fiduciária não são
dívidas próprio terrem.
Mas elas são a exceção para o arrematante
ficar responsável, já que será um leilão de
direitos, e aí você precisa voltar lá naquela
aula que eu falo de leilão judicial de
direitos.
Porque aí sim, além das dívidas do imóvel,
IPTU e condomínio, o arrematante pode ser responsável
pelo saldo devedor daquele financiamento que está aí
aberto e que tem a garantia da alienação
fiduciária.
Já porque se existir um leilão judicial desse
tipo, o que está indo a leilão não
é a propriedade e somente os direitos, já
que o devedor não é proprietário de fato
daquele imóvel e sim o credor.
Lembre disso em leilão judicial.
E nunca confunda com um leilão extrajudicial.
No leilão extrajudicial, o imóvel está indo a
leilão para a cobrança de uma dívida que
ficou garantida por uma alienação fiduciária.
Mas o objetivo daquele leilão lá é justamente
extinguir essa dívida.
Então essa dívida não sobra para o arrematante
em leilão extrajudicial.
Em leilão extrajudicial, realmente, o arrematante precisa ficar
de olho ali nas dívidas de imóvel, IPTU
e condomínio.
A dívida de alienação fiduciária que ficou garantida
ali pela alienação fiduciária não será transferida para
o arrematante porque o leilão extrajudicial existe exatamente
para isso.
No leilão judicial, quando existir uma alienação fiduciária
na matrícula daquele imóvel, você tem que lembrar
que você pode ser o responsável por pagar
essa dívida.
Reassista lá a aula de leilão judicial de
direitos aqui no módulo 3 do curso.
Dito isso, a gente vai entender agora como
funcionam as dívidas do imóvel no leilão judicial.
Vamos ver aqui o que fala o Código
de Processo Civil sobre a dívida propterrem que
existe no imóvel quando ele está indo a
um leilão judicial.
Artigo 908, parágrafo 1º que interessa para a
gente.
No caso de adjudicação ou alienação, os créditos
que recaem sobre o bem, inclusive de natureza
propterrem, subrogam-se sobre o respectivo preço, observada
a ordem de preferência.
Vamos traduzir aqui esse artigo.
No caso de adjudicação, adjudicar seria o próprio
credor escolher ficar com aquele imóvel.
Então, vamos supor que eu estou cobrando uma
dívida de 200 mil reais de alguém.
Essa pessoa não me pagou no decorrer de
um processo judicial.
Comecei a procurar bens dela e encontrei ali
um imóvel.
Esse imóvel eu poderia, como credora, falar para
o juiz, olha, eu quero que esse imóvel
vá a leilão.
Mas eu também tenho a opção de adjudicar
aquele imóvel.
Eu posso falar, olha, ele tem esse imóvel,
esse imóvel eu poderia ir a leilão, mas
eu aceito ficar com o imóvel em troca
da dívida.
Então, adjudicar seria isso.
E essa alienação aqui é realmente o que
importa para a gente, que é o leilão.
Então, vamos traduzir aqui para o que importa
para a gente.
No caso de leilão judicial, os créditos que
recaem sobre o bem, inclusive de natureza próprio
terreno, que são esses que a gente acabou
de estudar, os débitos do imóvel, IPTU, condomínio,
taxa de bombeira ali onde existir, imóvel foreiro,
se for o caso, e dívida de INSS,
se for o caso.
Subrogam-se sobre o respectivo preço.
O que significa subrogar sobre o preço?
Significa que essa dívida deve ser paga com
o produto da arrematação daquele leilão.
Então, o produto da arrematação é, de fato,
o valor da arrematação.
O valor que o arrematante está pagando por
aquele imóvel em um leilão judicial.
Observada a ordem de preferência.
E essa ordem de preferência aqui é realmente
o concurso de credores que a gente vai
estudar daqui em diante.
Então, o que esse artigo aqui, esse parágrafo
primeiro do artigo 908 do Código do Processo
Civil está falando para a gente?
Que em caso de leilão judicial, os débitos
próprio terreno, aqueles que recaem sobre o bem,
eles devem ser pagos preferencialmente com o valor
da arrematação.
Então, isso aí é uma garantia para o
arrematante.
O artigo 130, parágrafo único do Código Tributário
Nacional, ele fala sobre IPTU.
Então, ele é o artigo mais específico do
artigo 908 do Código do Processo Civil, porque
o artigo 908 do Código do Processo Civil,
ele fala de uma maneira geral sobre as
dívidas próprio terreno.
E o artigo 130, parágrafo único aqui do
Código Tributário Nacional, o CTN, ele fala do
IPTU.
Então, o que o artigo fala nesse parágrafo
único?
No caso de arrematação em asta pública, asta
pública é sinônimo de leilão público, a subrogação
da dívida de IPTU ocorre sobre o respectivo
preço.
Então, está falando também que o IPTU, ele
deve ser pago com o produto daquela arrematação.
Aqui a gente tem uns exemplos de jurisprudência
sobre o IPTU que exista num imóvel que
está sendo arrematado.
Jurisprudência é um conjunto de decisões reiteradas sobre
o mesmo assunto do mesmo tribunal.
Então, indica como é que aquele tribunal entende
e julga determinada matéria.
Essa jurisprudência aqui é do Superior Tribunal de
Justiça, que é o Tribunal Máximo para Matérias
Infraconstitucionais.
Então, é a última instância que uma matéria
infraconstitucional, ou seja, aquela matéria que não é
uma matéria constitucional, pode ser julgada.
Então, o STJ, ele tem realmente a última
palavra sobre essas matérias infraconstitucionais.
O que o STJ diz sobre as dívidas
de IPTU que existam naquele imóvel?
O ponto 1 aqui é o que interessa
para a gente.
A jurisprudência dessa Corte Superior, que é o
próprio STJ, já orientou que, em relação à
responsabilidade pelos débitos tributários incidentes sobre o imóvel,
quando de sua aquisição em asta pública, que
é leilão público, o artigo 130, parágrafo único
do CTN, que é o Código Tributário Nacional,
preleciona que a subrogação ocorre somente sobre o
respectivo preço.
Ao fazê-lo, o diploma legal exclui a
responsabilidade do adquirente em relação àqueles débitos anteriores
à arrematação.
Contudo, havendo débitos pendentes, persiste a obrigação do
proprietário original perante o fisco estadual, exatamente porque
é impossível a transferência do encargo tributário para
o arrematante.
O que essa jurisprudência está falando?
Ela está falando que se você arrematar um
imóvel em leilão judicial, o valor da dívida
de PTU deve ser paga com o valor
da arrematação.
Se, por acaso, o valor da arrematação não
for suficiente para quitar a integralidade daquela dívida
de PTU, a diferença deve ser cobrada do
antigo proprietário e não do arrematante.
Então, um exemplo aqui.
Você quer arrematar um imóvel que está sendo
levado a leilão e aquele imóvel é um
imóvel de rua, uma casa de rua, tem
débitos de PTU que somam 100 mil reais.
O valor da arrematação foi de 80 mil
reais.
Esse valor da arrematação vai ser utilizado para
pagar essa dívida de PTU existente.
Mas veja, o valor da arrematação é de
80 mil e o valor da dívida é
de 100 mil.
Então, logo, o valor da arrematação não quita
integralmente o valor da dívida.
Vai ter uma diferença de 20 mil reais.
Quem será o responsável por pagar essa dívida,
essa diferença de 20 mil reais?
O antigo proprietário, se no edital do leilão
constar expressamente o artigo 130, parágrafo único do
Código Tributário Nacional.
É isso que essa jurisprudência do STJ está
falando.
Mas a gente precisa ficar muito atento porque
o edital do leilão pode colocar regras diferentes
do que a lei estipula.
O que a lei estipula?
Que dívidas condomínio e PTU, as dívidas próprio
terreno, devem ser pagas com o valor da
arrematação.
Mas o edital do leilão pode colocar de
forma diversa e, nesse caso, vai valer o
edital do leilão.
Por isso que você precisa ficar muito atento
ao que cada edital fala, porque cada edital
pode mudar essa regra.
Então, aqui, de novo, um exemplo de mais
uma jurisprudência do próprio STJ.
A gente acabou de ver que o STJ
diz que, se tiver lá no edital do
leilão o artigo 130, parágrafo único do CTN,
as dívidas tributárias serão pagas com o valor
da arrematação e, se não for suficiente para
pagar com o valor da arrematação, o antigo
proprietário, ou seja, o devedor, será cobrado pela
aquela diferença e não o arrematante.
Vamos ver agora o que o STJ fala
nesse outro caso.
Ponto 1 também é o que importa para
a gente.
Então, se por acaso você pegar um edital
do leilão que não fala que o débito
tributário será subrogado no valor da arrematação de
acordo com o artigo 130 parágrafo único do
CTN, se o edital falar que a responsabilidade
vai ser do arrematante pelos débitos tributários, o
arrematante vai ser o responsável.
Inclusive, é isso que o STJ diz que
tem uma posição super consolidada sobre esse assunto.
Então, essa é a importância de você verificar
se existe, em cada edital de leilão judicial
que você for participar, a expressa previsão de
que os débitos tributários serão subrogados no preço
da arrematação.
E aí sim você pode ficar tranquilo, porque
se o valor da arrematação não for suficiente
para pagar aquele débito tributário, aquela diferença não
pode ser repassada ao arrematante, vai ter que
ser cobrada do devedor.
Agora, se o edital não falar nada da
subrogação no preço dos débitos tributários, se o
edital passar essa responsabilidade para o arrematante, a
responsabilidade vai ser do arrematante, o arrematante não
poderá invocar lá o artigo 130 parágrafo único
do CTN porque o próprio edital passou a
responsabilidade para o arrematante, e esse é o
entendimento do STJ.
Aqui, mais uma jurisprudência, agora sobre condomínio.
A gente também viu que as dívidas próprio
-terreiro devem ser subrogadas no preço, incluindo nessas
dívidas próprio-terreiro, a gente tem um condomínio,
então, preferencialmente, o condomínio deve ser pago ali
com o valor da arrematação.
Ocorre que, para o condomínio o entendimento é
diferente do IPTU, do IPTU se constatar lá
o artigo 130 parágrafo único do CTN no
edital do leilão, não importa se o valor
da arrematação não vai ser suficiente para quitar
aquela dívida, aquela dívida não será repassada para
o arrematante, deve ser cobrada do antigo proprietário.
No condomínio, o entendimento é diferente, mesmo que
conste lá o artigo 908 parágrafo 1º do
CPC, se o valor da arrematação não for
suficiente para quitar o condomínio, a diferença do
condomínio será do arrematante.
Por isso, a importância da gente sempre verificar.
Aqui no ponto 1 dessa jurisprudência do STJ
o que que fala?
Nos termos da jurisprudência dessa Corte, em se
tratando a dívida de condomínio de obrigação próprio
-terreiro, constando do edital de Praça a existência
de ônus incidentes sobre o imóvel, o arrematante
é responsável pelo pagamento das despesas condominais vencidas,
ainda que essas sejam anteriores à arrematação.
Admitindo-se, inclusive, a sucessão processual do antigo
executado pelo arrematante.
Ou seja, o executado, que é o proprietário
daquele imóvel, está sendo cobrado ali pela aquela
dívida de condomínio, teve o leilão, o valor
do leilão não foi suficiente para pagar aquela
dívida de condomínio e aí essa diferença vai
ser cobrada do arrematante.
Então essa é a importância de sempre analisar,
em alguns casos vai ser necessário analisar também
o concurso de credores.